all right look we got a Bobby J in here
it's the bootle cat podcast you might
know him from uh one of the biggest
shows ever wilding out for show for show
how did you get discovered uh by Nick uh
well me and Nick Nick been knowing me
since I was like probably like eight and
nine years old wow yeah I mean [__] the
Kids Choice Awards like a long time ago
and uh he'd already told me that he like
had a movie idea you want to do with me
you know he had a TV he wanted to give
me like a talk show right so uh we had
tried that we tried to do two talk shows
on MTV
um they didn't pan out we did a movie
together school dance it was good it
came out I mean got good reviews Hood
classic and what I like to call it if
you ask me is it on tubing classic
um no we look we we own stars and [__]
okay good all right
Classics are all on to be though we
might be on 2b2 though I think we
everywhere I think we own you ever just
watch TV movies for fun
hell yeah sometimes they're [__] wild
hilarious I feel like I could be a
director and get a movie on 2B you could
be you could direct and star in them
iPhone off your iPhone for sure with no
audio no microphone they're just off
everything off of them so what were you
doing like um prior because if you were
at the Kids Choice Awards when you were
nine what were you doing at nine were
you like uh I was on I was doing uh at
the time I think I was doing Tracy
Morgan show uh NBC so you were on his
show yeah I played his son oh then I've
seen you before yeah probably more than
likely yeah I love Tracy Morgan from
there on I did uh I did That's So Raven
oh you just ran the gauntlet huh yeah I
was I did I was down who was cooler uh
Raven Simon or Tracy Morgan
um
I'd have to say
for different reasons both of them was
equally cool in my opinion very
political the only reason only reason
why though is because like Tracy was
like that was like like a like a big bro
like you know what I mean like like he
was an OG figure in my life Raven was
like a big sister so they both served
like a dope purpose and and a good time
in my life when I'm out here working I'm
away from a lot of I mean biological
families right you know I mean try to
take me and we go shopping we hit the
mall you know I mean Raven to take me to
hang out we go to lunch and stuff like
that my big sisters back home would do
so they both served an adult practice in
my life when I was young coming up in
the industry both were cool though hell
yeah super cool are you still close with
either of them yeah I actually just
talked to Raven probably like a few
months ago if that like if it wasn't
more recent than that I recently just
started raving though were you working
with Orlando Brown on that show yeah
when you were working with him did you
have any idea that he was crazy as he is
Orlando's not crazy in my opinion
Orlando Orlando's one of the most
talented individuals very talented guy
his interviews in life are [__] wild
though I think he does that because he's
he's an intelligent person he knows what
he's doing he knows how to get clicks he
knows how to get he knows what it takes
he's like a walk yeah he's definitely a
viral yeah he want to go viral that's
all it is I don't believe he's he's not
crazy at all right Orlando got sense
believe me when I tell you the boy got
all the sense y'all could thank that man
some people could have too much sense
though maybe that that could be it yeah
but one thing about it that boy ain't
crazy if he has me he know what he doing
so when you guys you were working with
Orlando on uh That's So Raven did you
guys have a close relationship back then
yeah that was my dog man like he was in
the music so you know I mean one of the
people that helped me learn how to like
really write raps and you know what I
mean was a big bro figure as well like
kind of you know I mean he was a dope
dude growing up and still is in my
opinion like um
he's entertaining if if you don't know
him personally if you ain't seen
sorry for you but I know that [__] in
the real way so he's entertaining
I don't know I mean he doesn't seem like
a bad guy
he'd be saying some wild [__] bro yeah I
mean but a lot of [__] do they just
pay attention to him because like oh he
was on Disney so well he's not he's not
allowed to say wow [__] that's true you
know do you ever feel like that you had
to shake that for a while being like the
Disney Channel guy oh yeah absolutely
but one thing about it is I've always
been me like if you believe I'm a Disney
Channel [__] that means that's just
what you believe I don't really give a
damn like I was just wondering because
like you know I feel like if you're
you know we've seen so many people come
from the Disney Channel on the pop side
but not as much on the hip-hop side yeah
so it's something kind of different you
know yeah most definitely I mean for me
if people do their research with me to
SC that I started with the hip-hop and I
started rapping I was coming up rapping
Bow Wow I did the Apollo I went through
all the uh Sally uh Ricky Lake Jenny
Jones all these yeah he was on all those
shows man I'm oh gee Kev I'm not
[__] man I'm nosy man you ain't seen
Role Models man
come on man I'm the Og man I know you
don't seen Role Models kids come on you
were on
Jenny Jones and Ricky Lake yes bro
that's the one two punch Raphael I did
all of them Sally I see two Sally I did
them all man Jesus I'm a big dog man
I've been doing this [__] man I'm trying
to tell you you were on there just like
it's like the kid rapper I was rapping
yeah yeah I even did a [__] I don't rap
no Maury
what come on man I'm I'm a Og man you've
been on I didn't did it all in all the
most Unthinkable places if you think
about it bro Maury who else isn't rap no
more I don't know man come on man I was
rapping a lot of people needed to wrap
it up on Maury yeah that was the problem
they said Bobby said these [__] can't
wrap it up so you just gonna spit a rat
[__] it jeez what was uh for you as a
kid which show was like the coolest for
you to like be on because that's gotta
out of those talk shows uh talk shows
okay yeah the ones we just talked about
the you know the toxic ones
I'll probably have to say Maury just
because I was a little bit older and I
was more familiar with Maury by the time
I wasn't that familiar with Sally and
Ricky Lake and Jane Jones When I had
went on them I was stealing like five
years old at that time five six years
old somewhere like that but by the time
I made it the Maury I had already seen
Mori on TV like I you could probably see
it it's somewhere on the internet you'll
see me I had a more I did the Mori
impression you know I mean like I did
the whole I [__] be when uh when the
baby ain't theirs when they find out
it's funny I did that 20 years ago
before it became a man right before it
was a thing yeah boy I did that 20 years
ago on Mario like you can find that
somewhere I swear to God like it's funny
as hell to just see that type of [__]
now but yeah like if you think back to
those like talk shows like some of the
premises of those shows were absolutely
wild yeah absolutely it'd be like a
trans member of the KKK reveals that his
son is black next
and you'd be like whoa what the [__]
where did they play these [__] people
so for you
um talk about like where you're at with
the music now like obviously putting out
music like are you fully committed to
the music [__] or I mean you're just in
a container right yeah I'm still I'm I'm
still entertained at anything you know
what I mean I still do wilding out of
course right uh that new episode season
19 and 20 Aaron right now wow what I'm
saying 20 years yeah for sure and um
[__]
uh the music is like that's my first
love that's always going to be a part of
me that's always going to be who I am
and what I am and the way for me to
express who Bobby is like people gotta
people gotta be able to separate the
Entertainer and the roles I've played
right things you've seen me do on
television from who I am is a real in
real life where I come from Frank why I
am the way I am how I was brought up you
know I mean like people don't people
tend to not understand like oh my gosh
how are you could or how are you or a
gangster how are you this that in the
third or whatever the case that you were
doing this I said I I'm one of the few
that didn't change and on where I came
from one of you one of the few to stay
true to where I came from I came I think
there's like a difference between being
like real and being like a gangster yeah
exactly this is like a real dude like
right in my definition of gangster is
the fact that [__] I bought my mama
house I move my family out there I I
allow my family to see different things
and and more opportunity than they would
have seen if I had not been blessed to
do the things I did like that's gangster
to me it ain't gangster that do nothing
illegal what's Gangsta to me is being
able to change the trajectory of your
family for being able to put your family
in a better position and better
predicting me you feel what I'm saying
so what people have it misconstrued so
they feel like when I talk the way I'm
talking when I speak on the subject that
I do speak onto my music that I'm
portraying some other type of Lifestyle
right what they consider gangster but
that's not what it is I'm being me I'm
speaking on things I know things I came
up around things I've done in my own
personal life that's why I said people
have to learn to separate the
Entertainer and the roles I play for me
you if you want to get to know me just
listen to the music I'm not being nobody
but me I'm not speaking on nothing but
the things that I know the things that
I've experienced what up y'all we gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
folks at my bookie look baseball season
it is back in full swing and my bookie
your One-Stop shop for everything you
need to get money off of your favorite
baseball teams your favorite baseball
players all the betting needs they got
you man so many different options
including money lines the Run lines
totals Futures all of it my bookie gives
you plenty of ways to bet on your
favorite teams and players and get some
of that money you can also take
advantage of the brand new mybookie
money bag it gives you the chance to
secure a bet on your favorite team or
player at crazy boosted odds what you
got to do right now sign up in my bookie
use the promo code bootleg to secure a
first deposit bonus up to a thousand
dollars now how that works is if you
deposit two hundred dollars
you get to play with 300 instantly
that's what we're doing all right all
you got to do is use that promo code
bootleg to claim your bonus ASAP so look
if you're a baseball fan there's so much
excitement when it comes to betting
baseball you know I would say baseball
is one of the funnest and easiest
Sports the gamble on if you really know
what the [__] you're doing plus we got
the NBA Playoffs coming
so much happening with the playoffs we
got the playing tournament we got the uh
let's see
I love the series the Cavaliers versus
Nets Knicks because the Nets are not
playing the Cavaliers the Knicks are
wrong New York team Suns vs Clippers
[__] Hammer the Suns minus 200 to
beat the Clippers it's gonna happen all
right so look go to my bookie right now
sign up with that promo code bootleg and
get that first deposit bonus ladies and
gentlemen it's so easy I promise you my
bookies got it covered for you baseball
uh of course basketball NBA playoffs
Futures you go I mean they got the
casino popping they got Blackjack they
got roulette they got it all
mybookie.ag promo code bootleg cab promo
code bootleg actually go sign up you'll
see it it's right there
and we gotta give a big shout out to the
good folks of blue chew that's right
ladies and gentlemen it's getting a
little hot outside that's right it's
getting super hot it is getting hot
finally tired of this [__] cold ass
weather you know what that means it's
[__] season baby that's right if you
are you know maybe dealing with a little
erectile dysfunction
it happens to the best of us you don't
have to be an old guy to get Ed you
might just have a we don't even say what
you might have but maybe you're dealing
with stress at work maybe you're dealing
with stress at home and you're not
performing up to par maybe your penis
could be a little bit more harder let's
be honest that's really what we're
talking about here right go to
bluetooth.com right now and use the
promo code bootleg and you can get a
month's supply for free that's right a
month supply for free at bluetooth.com
now a lot of people are asking what is
Bluetooth how does it work does it work
one of course it works two how does it
work it has the same active ingredients
as Viagra and Cialis but it's in a blue
chewable tablet yes it's a chewable all
right and the best part about it you
don't even have to go to the doctor's
office to get it it's all online you
don't have to have any sort of embarrass
embarrassing conversations with people
in regards to you know your junk now
working the way you want to to work or
whatever the [__] all you got to do is
go online to bluetooth.com
they're going to get you situated with
your first month for free as long as you
use that promo code bootleg free month
supply of Bluetooth use the promo code
bootleg it gets delivered straight to
your door discrete packaging plus they
got the new mint flavor which is the
same exact active ingredient is Levitra
so many ways you can Bluetooth man I'll
tell you this though it's about to get
hot as [__] outside you're about to hit
that spring break you want to make sure
you're equipped you know what I mean
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg get a
free month on me all you do is pay five
dollars in shipping what's up y'all
bootleg Kev here got to tell you about
our homies uh who are our new sponsor at
the podcast and it's so dope that we got
to work with them because I've been
using their product for so long I'm
talking about the homies at King Palm
baby that's right shout out to King Palm
y'all don't know all natural
tobacco-free no additive Leaf wraps all
right they're literal Leafs all right
and when I tell you they're the best uh
they're the industry leader when it
comes to the tobacco-free Natural Leaf
wrap situation and my [__] is this they
got these uh amazing wraps that come
with these
flavor infused terpene tips and these
ones right here
the red rains are a movie shout out to
the red Reigns because the dope thing
about these is they taste like a goddamn
energy drink when you squeeze the tip
all right there's so much you can get
when it comes to King Palm so many dough
products of course their stable product
is that empty Leaf tube with the
pre-installed filter tip no need to lick
or roll it all you do is just pack it
with what you want some of them legal
herbs and get it in all right and check
this out right now you can go to the
website kingpom.com use the promo code
bootleg Kev for 50 off so much we're
talking about rollable wraps hemp cones
and all the essential smoking
accessories you will ever need for the
smoothest smoke easy to use go order
them right now kingpom.com with that
promo code bootleg calf or go to your
local smoke shop even that 7-Eleven
that's on the Block they're gonna have
the King Palm they are the pioneer of
the natural Leaf wrap and they're
getting you hooked up right now at
kingpom.com promo code bootleg Kev half
off all right shout out to King pong the
Watermelons are fire too I'm gonna go
with the watermelon and the energy drink
the red rain gas or you can just go with
just the normal boys
you know what I mean
man who would like to smoke just
straight natural organic Don't Panic
it's organic man free of tobacco and
additives go [__] with King Palm using
that promo code bootleg kept at
kingpom.com let's get back to the
interview have you got to tap in with uh
Tech N9 yet yeah that's my dog like we
that's my man's I haven't been you know
in Texas I was probably that's not what
I've been doing since I was probably
like five six years old that's family
like have you been to the like Strange
Music headquarters yeah the warehouse
the big I heard it's crazy they got car
washes and [__] car washes man man got
all his merch right there man the man
got a there's a billion dollar operation
going on right there man my man got a
ground not yeah legitimate yeah for so
long I do feel like he was kind of like
the only guy like nationally at least
getting recognition from Kansas City but
now you know you're doing your thing
I've actually shout out to uh sleazy
world go absolutely is there anybody
else out there that you want to shine
somebody
um yeah man it's a lot of young people
coming up by my city um we got my boy
flash Gotti
um he's a dope rapper coming out of
Kansas City that's one of my close
Partners that's my brother uh you got a
lot of let me see who else we got coming
out of the city man you got uh my boy
Steph up coming out of KC man you gotta
as a young lady by the name I think
Scott Sky Cali or Scott Calais or
something like that coming from Kansas
City young lady is dope she's a rapper
um bro we got so much talent like he
would be you'd be we got a young
nicknamed 22. uh and the [__] Super
Bowl yeah we went in Super Bowls we got
all type of talented musicians and
artists coming out bro Kansas City just
just keep your eye on Kansas City man
let's keep your eye on us man we got
some [__] coming man is it weird like
because I feel like as somebody who's
not from L.A do you where do you stay at
do you stay out here you live in L.A
yeah you can't wear the case you had
certain areas yeah you can't uh I just
be in the valley so I can wear whatever
has been but yeah I'm saying I live in I
live in a nice area yeah so it doesn't
matter but you know there's like I feel
like the KC has like a very specific hat
you can't wear yeah they do they got
like the I think the the Royals cap you
can't wear in certain spots of La like I
said I live in a nice area so I wear
whatever hat whenever I want to that's
fair man check you out yo you were in
Role Models you were the little kid in
Role Models yeah man ain't me bro yes
crazy yeah man who was in that was that
the dude from American Pie in that movie
yeah and Paul Rudd Paul Rudder and uh
Christmas classroom Superbad what's the
kid's name or the dude's name from uh
American Pie uh Sean William Scott yeah
my dog that one that's one of my
favorites yo he's [__] hilarious man
isn't he crazy I wonder like what
happened to him bro because he was in
everything and I really enjoyed him in
movies and I feel like that [__] ran up
their bag and got out of the way yeah I
mean [__] when you run it up you can go
sit your head down for a couple years
that was the one where you guys were
like in the park like doing like the
jousting and [__] yeah yeah yeah oh
you're the kid in that movie come on you
were the badass kid in that we'll get
into it man it is what it is man now
you're you didn't you didn't get much
taller no I told you I've been told and
that I've been told her now I'm the same
size I just I just grew in a I mean look
I got grown in the face region but I
ain't really grow this much I was a good
movie yeah it was fun that was a fun
movie film like I said Sean William
Scott probably one of my favorite people
I ever worked with too he was great yeah
oh my God I love Stifler man one of his
best characters yeah whoever and then
the dude
yeah I just spoke with him not too long
ago that's my guy too people don't know
he do he he's in the music he's behind a
lot of voices and things in the music
bro that man is hey man that dude's a
talented Dude too for you is it like
kind of cool to be so like
multi-talented where you can go and get
an acting bag you can go get the music
back you can go to TV like have you ever
done any Voice work for cartoons or
anything or trying to do any of that
yeah I didn't did uh I didn't did
Boondocks I haven't been on Boondocks
yeah which episode uh that's my the
Little Milton to shine episode the
smokes with cigarettes was that season
three
because we go to season three and I
can't quite remember that season three
is when Aaron Magruder left and I was
just kind of guy yeah I can't remember
exactly what season it was but I know it
was a uh I did that I did a Shark Tale
with Will Smith and all them peoples I
did that's great I did the original
Cloudy with a chance to meet balls oh
yeah I did a couple different uh yeah
animation Voice works would you ever get
into like uh writing any TV or like
trying to like do scripts or anything
yeah yeah for sure absolutely that's
something I definitely am going to and
then currently I mean developing certain
situations and things like that and
content to produce on my own for sure
um what talk talk about the music what
do you got out what do you got coming
out uh right now I got a single out card
immediate
um dope record
the first single of the project the EP I
mean a little small little sample plat
I'm gonna get a photo record EP man
called No capping volume one just let
them know ain't no cap involved man just
get to know Bobby that's the real me man
it's what it is it's what it's gonna be
you did what I'm saying any features no
I I probably won't I probably won't do
no features because I want to earn my
respect on my own first I don't want no
I don't want no I don't want no handouts
from no even if I get a feature I
probably won't release it until I feel
like I'm respected as a standalone
artist first I don't want to take the
feature out too you mean let a [__]
boost my who could you get a free
feature from right now if you wanted
though Tech Nine I think would do it
obviously yeah I could probably call
Tech trade the truth yeah I think I can
get a call into Jim Jones I think I can
get a call in a couple people that'll
[__] with me for the free ski do you
think if Nick Cannon gave you a future
you'd use it
um it depends on the record
I will say this Nick has a lot of great
unreleased music now I can't speak on
the [__] that he choose to put out but
he has a lot of great people hear the
song with Chris Brown recently that I'm
not sure if it was him singing on that
song or not but it didn't sound like he
was on it it was a good song If you know
what song it came out like last year
and he'd be behind a lot of [__] too
like a lot of dope ass he's like the
hardest working guy ever Yeah by far I
very like that's why I don't understand
how he has the time to make all the
children he makes because this [__]
don't like so I know for a fact now you
don't sleep you [__] and you work and
you do it 24 7. yeah cause you got to
work to take care of the the [__]
part the dude is the dude is he's a one
of a kind fella yeah have you babysitter
for me hell no them kids my size what
I'm gonna do
all of them even the newborn
all of them my size what I'm gonna do
because I ain't gonna lie one cry and
I'm gonna be wanting to fight we're the
same size what I'm gonna do like where
do we go from here we're the same size
what do I do I can't pick you up and
rock you [__] pick him up rock me I'm
stressed you keep crying I want to cry
just I can't babysit bro yeah being
around him do you like take up any like
pointers for like how he's able to do so
much at once because I always like it
breaks my brain to be like this dude
he's doing TV he's doing wilding out
he's doing radio the [__] is like um
[__] half of the world he's he's a
legitimate superhero like he's like he
does it all and you never know really
how he [__] does it but you just know
he's doing it all and he's getting it
done and he's doing it efficiently
because he doesn't slack in no parts I
think he's got magic in the turban it's
the turban it's something he's like a
genie something about dude is different
he's wired different he's the baby daddy
Genie bruh he's a different dude bro
make wishes come shout out to Nick bro
he's a different guy bro you different
hey we gotta stop the interview shout
out to our our great sponsors at hard
Dean Las Vegas you see him they gave me
this amazing box to keep
my things in what kind of things
premium things that you can buy at
Harding Las Vegas yeah if you're in
Vegas stop off at hard Dean tell them I
sent you they'll take care of you all
right number one dispensary I've ever
been into the nicest dispensary in the
world they got their own [__] scent
they got the biggest craziest selection
of Premium cannabis you will ever see in
your life you walk in and you feel like
they just treat you like family as soon
as you walk in all right so look this is
what you're gonna do you're gonna go to
hardinglasvegas.com check them out go
follow them online Harding underscore
Las Vegas and when you're in Las Vegas
this is your first stop
you don't go to the [__] Casino you
don't go to the you go to [__]
Jardine get situated say bootleg have
sent me I heard about him on the Blue
Lake Cab podcast they're gonna take care
of you they'll throw a little extra on
the on the extra you know what I mean go
follow them Hardy and underscore Las
Vegas and of course you can also follow
them right now by going to their website
check out what they got going on man
they got the gear for sale they just
dropped their own pair of Filas
hardinglasvegas.com gotta give a shout
out to our oh geez my dogs at Odd Socks
baby they've been [__] with us from
day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and Butt-head socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and Butthead
drawski's bro
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout
at oddsoxofficial.com using the promo
code bootleg so go right now
oddsoxofficial.com my first uh
suggestion would be get you a pair or a
pack of the Odd Socks Basics the black
and the whites those are my go-to's and
then you gotta [__] with some of these
Big Lebowski socks
and they just got Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got [__] South Park
come on bruh what are we talking about
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview uh what what was the
moment on wild 'n out uh what's like
like your top two or three favorite
moments on wild and out
um and who were they against
uh
I think one of my like my my
one of my top favorite moments is
probably uh a wild style like one of my
first like toms really getting off for
real for real and wild style
uh with my dog Chico Bean man tried the
Chico Bean yeah shout out my dog that my
[__] man uh it was my first time like
really like like kind of my coming out
party right right right right like
letting them solidifying myself like
okay this kid going he gonna he gonna be
able to hang with the big dogs for the
seasons to come I had that and then I
had one with DC that ended an episode
that was dope and I'm like yeah all
right that was like my I'm here what
happens like when celebrities come in
that can't
do the [__] do you guys help them write
lines man sometimes like in the moment
we'd be like we might come over like hey
man should I say this but it's like it's
hard to be playing they trying to
probably think of some [__] to say on
their own and you tired of waiting on
them they brain wrecking you you trying
to tell them to say some somebody else
probably whispering in their head and
say it'd be a lot bro like but for the
most part if they drown let them drown
bro also like they figure it out if
they're coming to Wild and out you would
hope that even if they're not rappers
they have something type something like
do they at least but like we gotta we
got great a great team of producers and
stuff that try to help and prepare our
guests and get them right you know what
I mean so like like when they know who
they're gonna go against ahead of time
so at least they have something
um for the most part like the the guests
they can pick who they want to they can
pick a cast member if they want to like
a person if they want to go after so
they can prepare for it you know I mean
to make it easy on the guess you know
what I mean so they have a good time
who's been the most offended celebrity
on the show since you've been on [__]
got Superman because I remember there
was a that was a Blac Chyna
wait Nick let Azalea banks on on the
show yeah that was that was the only
episode where somebody was like really
like super duper bothered like we got
another episode where somebody else
wait who is bothered because of you I
don't want to say just say it I don't
care she's because she gonna be on
Twitter in the morning trying to trip
with me listen shouting I don't want no
smoke rapper yes she a rabbit man she's
an angry little rapper too she saw an
angry little right okay
she's just angry bruh she be tripping I
shot her be flashing out I don't want no
smoke on Twitter yeah on Twitter in
person Shawty Shawty like that I believe
she already like that I don't want no
smoke with the mama man hey it's a
little mama not little mama that's not
who it is little mama no it's not her
mama I'm saying I was calling shouting
little mama like Lil Mama baby shout out
not cardi B no hell no absolutely not
not Hardy not not cardi not it's not
she's a female rapper but she ain't Iggy
Azalea
you're not gonna get it
out of me you're not gonna get it out of
him damn Azalea Banks man that's that's
signing up for
huh if you ain't catchy you ain't catch
it
what city is this girl from
Houston land of Vegas Houston I said
Houston Atlanta Vegas oh see that's
they're not from Vegas because I don't
know anybody so he's from Houston Vegas
so she's from Houston or Atlanta can we
at least get that is it Houston or
Atlanta it's used Atlanta Vegas okay I
don't know if he was born in Houston but
then she grew up in Atlanta but then she
moved to Vegas
she was selling [__] well maybe that's
why she got mad at you because you're
exposing her her business let me show
you all the way off bro I just shot her
not from neither one of them places well
listen man uh new single go get it yes
go get that are you uh like when why
when I goes on tour you go on the tour
um no I'm gonna be on the tour yeah he
ain't got enough money no I wouldn't say
that I just don't be on the tour like
Nick I need this and he's like no we're
good nah Nick no that's my dog I come on
the tour for free if you add me to my
button no you wouldn't yeah I would for
free for free for free you got to pay
for your own rooms you gotta pay for
your own room okay okay y'all gotta pay
me okay favorite room make sure I get
their first class like a player or Nick
Aaron right now the season yeah new
episode any movie stuff coming yeah man
I got some stuff in the works man we
cooking up some stuff I can't speak on
too much but some stuff in the words
cool stuff going on all right man well
go get the music appreciate you pulling
up and we're gonna have this guy
freestyle different YouTube video boom